[Applaudissements]
alors
[Musique]
il s'agit là à aller voilà chacun laver
une voiture mais potvin et peuvent laver
a ils veulent laver la même ensemble à
d'accord non non à chacun sa voiture eu
d'accord très bien alors attention je
faisais là d'avoir pendant douze ans un
éléphant bleu vous allez devoir laver
une voiture le avec une attitude la plus
sexy possible nos invités et tous les
chroniqueurs vont mieux notés attention
c'est parti
[Musique]
on avait déjà failli
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et bastille dit on
regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
m
issa doumbia exceptionnel merci ça
vraiment et ça ça a été ça se voit ça se
voit à la baleine voiture gillet veut il
et il est mort cette amélioration